okay so squid game has a pretty big
ending not only does it reveal a big
twist about one of the fan favorite
characters but it also sets up a lot of
things for the future that i'll no doubt
be milking in 400 videos over the next
three days although it seems pretty
straightforward we actually have a lot
of theories about what's going on
including how illness planned his death
why he could still be alive and the way
that the front man is selected hopefully
after you watch this video it'll give
you a new appreciation for the show and
make you think that everything isn't as
simple as it seems yes it's all
connected
now the series ends with gihon going to
see illnam as he lies in his deathbed
though gihon initially wants to kill him
he agrees to play one last game with the
old man in which they bet on the fate of
a homeless man out in the cold illness
says that should no one help the man
come the stroke of midnight that he will
win and in doing so it'll show just how
selfish that humanity is however if
someone does come and help him it'll
prove that the mentality he's had his
entire life is wrong and that gihan's
way of looking at things is indeed right
just as the clock hits 12 the police and
a good samaritan arrive to help the man
but illness dies exactly as the clock
strikes midnight
it's a very poetic scene and it starts a
brand new day with gihon carrying a
brand new mind state however what if
this was all actually a game in itself
and ilan planned it all out perfectly
including the exact time that he would
die well it's an idea that's stuck with
me since i first watched the show
everything just seems so neat and the
fact that things happen down to the
exact second seems very very suspicious
the clock is constantly ticking away in
the background and it gets focused
brought to it every couple of minutes
within the scene to remind us about
midnight this is similar to the games
themselves in which we had constant
attention brought to the time limits
upon it hitting all the zeros those
still in play were killed and zero zero
zero zero is of course another way of
saying midnight just in the same way
that the players were killed when this
number was hit ilnam dies too and it is
possible that he's planned this entire
thing out now the first thing we have to
look at is how illnam would orchestrate
things so perfectly
personally i believe that the water is
in fact the key to it there are two
scenarios that i could see happening and
that is that it's either lace with a
poison that takes exactly 25 minutes to
kill someone or that it's a sedative
that does the same thing now let's look
at the scene for ourselves and how it's
set up gee hun is sent a card with an
address on it and he goes to it to find
the illness there if he doesn't go then
illness doesn't have to enact this plan
and thus he can just relax and not go
this route however if gihan does show up
an illness can ask for a glass of water
which will give him exactly 25 minutes
until his death now after drinking the
water ilnam asks to play a game and says
that come midnight that they will know
the outcome however should gihon have
given him it slightly later and he could
save five past and so on and so forth
the clock is clearly there for a reason
and so much attention is brought to it
in the scene and it just seems like ill
nam has it there for himself just after
giving illness the water gihon turns
around to look at it and we can see that
it's 36 minutes past so illness would
have taken a drink likely on the 35
minute mark in the scene ilnam seemingly
uses it as a means to play the game as
it adds a ticking clock to the scenario
but he could also be using it to let him
know exactly how much time he has left
now because of this it could also open
up the possibility that he is still
alive and that this entire thing is
somewhat of another game that we'll talk
about later on in the video much in the
same way that there could be poison
within the water there might also be a
sedative that makes someone appear dead
couple this with the heart rate monitors
and it could be possible that they were
either programmed to flatline once
whatever's in the water took hold or
that illness heart rate is so low that
it's practically undetectable this means
that he might not be dead and this
entire scenario could all be a game
within itself the situation is a weird
one with illness being in a hospital bed
at the top of a tower and we also know
that the front man is indeed there as he
appears after giuhan is left and there's
also of course the homeless man ilam
says he's been sitting there for hours
but this position seems very convenient
if our theory is right then the game
runners could have kidnapped someone
drug them and then dumped them on the
street immediately opposite to the
building so that ilnam could play this
final game along with gihon water is
also potentially symbolic as if our
theory from our last video is right then
ilnam has used it to try and get out
things before just before the marbles
game it seems that the character has wet
himself but there's an empty bottle of
water right by his head potentially he
poured this over himself to make himself
seem weak said he wouldn't be picked for
the marbles and this would mean that
he'd either get a free pass or he could
pretend to be executed in order to avoid
the bridge game now where the theory
about him still being alive falls down
is that the front man closes his eyes
and he looks out over the city he
remembers their conversation after the
marbles game and it very much feels like
a final farewell giving someone water as
they lie on their deathbed is also seen
in many cultures as a final act of
kindness which this moment definitely
comes across as though i do think
illness is dead i also think that he may
have orchestrated the full thing with
the water and there is a lot to think
about now if you're enjoying the video
so far we'd massively appreciate the
thumbs up as it goes a long way to
helping out the channel if this is your
first time here then welcome to the
heavy squid game show i'm your host paul
aka carl milkington now let's get into
the rest of the theories now in this
series we learn that the games have been
going on for decades for years and years
and years there have been players
selected which have been whittled down
until there's just one at the end of
episode five huang jun ho comes across
the file for his brother and we learn
near the end of the series that he's
actually the front man but why is it
just him who's running the show when
there's been so many other players well
potentially the ending of the series
gives us a big clue towards white only
the front man who's remained in an
authority position at the end of the
series we watch as gehan comes across
another card from the recruiter and he
calls it just as he's about to board the
plane to go and see his daughter gihon
ends up turning around to go after those
in charge but it could be that something
similar also happened with the front man
potentially this second card is somewhat
of recruitment for those in charge and
it's only once someone who wins calls it
that they enter into another game in
which they work their way into an
authority role now i would absolutely
love it if this second game was true and
that the next season revolved around
gehan returning to the island only to
find himself as part of another game in
which he was fighting to gain control of
the organization so that he could take
them down if it was offered up to him
that the prize for next time is the
chance to become the leader of the games
then this would give him the opportunity
to stop them himself potentially there
have been several frontmen that we don't
know about and it's only recently that
in ho took on the monaca the person
before him could have been taken down by
inho only to have him step in and run
the operation for himself under ilnam's
guidance the show is of course a comment
on capitalism and it could very much be
a metaphor for how the poor often just
end up being integrated into the system
once they get high enough up the ladder
now all three characters are people that
shows the games over their families
illness mentions his wife and children
throughout the show but they're not
there at his death bed making me think
that their relationship with a character
fell apart because of his focus on the
games inho has the opportunity to go off
with his brother but instead he shoots
him to return to his authority role
mirroring this gihon can go and meet his
daughter but instead he remains behind
and misses his flight so that he can be
entangled with the game's operation it's
a pretty sad finale because we now know
that he sacrificed his happiness to
ultimately go back into this thing
that's ended up losing him his family in
the first place we have to remember that
not only did gihan lose his daughter but
he also lost his mother much in the same
way that the authority figures in squid
game lost out on their family he's very
much doing the same thing and because of
this it could put him on a path that
leads to him becoming the new front man
or potentially even the new illness due
to the vips it is possible that the
squid games all take place in a number
of countries and we know from the ending
of episode 5 that we're barely just
scratching the surface in terms of
what's really going on
either way it is possible that gihon is
still in the game he's just completely
unaware of it
there may be a bigger one at play that
we don't know about yet and i'd
absolutely love to see that unveiled as
we head into season 2. now obviously i'd
also love to hear your thoughts so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we've actually joined forces with benq
to give away some amazon gift cards and
all you have to do is go on the post
that's linked in the description and
follow the instructions if you're in the
market for a brand new projector we've
also done a big review of the w1800i on
our last squid game video and there's a
15 off voucher in the description below
if you want to save some money and grab
a brand new one now if you want to watch
that full squid game video it will be
linked on screen right now we've also
got one breaking down all the hidden
details in the series including the
easter eggs foreshadowing and clues that
something else is going on if not then
thank you for sending through this video
i hope you've enjoyed it i hope that you
also enjoy the rest of your week you
take care of yourself mate you've been
the best i've been paul and i'll see you
on the next one take care peace